hello look into the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang it every tuesday at two p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com i'm
your host tanya Dwyer joined by Mary
Kish and Scott butterworth how are you
doing folks do it I think that was your
getting on so far like of all the odds
that I've heard you say bad that was a
really good one I was waiting for I was
gonna say the gamespot com cuz I don't
know if it redirects it doesn't I don't
think that it goes to song my check
still to video games com actually
directs to gamespot I know right never
knew that till I found out on this show
on this very couch the via the gamespot
com ghost is [ __ ] don't go there it's
real this great looking website whoo so
what you we probably tried to buy the
heavens we've probably Marcellus yes a
good chance it's literally says the
gamescom interested in this domain and
then it has a weird like IRC chat thing
they're just like you just talk to
someone they're waiting it's always like
okay put how much money you're gonna
give them for the set all right here we
go and ice ah the other euro then I was
real good right now impress them Bitcoin
I'm will travel bid in Japan man I used
to own so many URLs that were like just
terrible but now might actually be where
my I just stopped using them I gained
the PDA that's like a real [ __ ] thing
now I got like 15 years ago hen you
would be a rich man right now if you'd
actually like kept up with anything
he'll be like five hundred dollars
something I mean yeah not super rich I
think that was a hole there was an
industry devoted it and it's still kind
of as a problem like we have them TV com
I think we own mp3 I'm not sure we might
know music writing here I think we'd
hotels.com as well that's huge pretty
good one that's worth millions you can
build a show out of like just word +
calm and see what hands cuz like I don't
know what happens when you go to TV com
something's gonna happen go to TV com
fine CBS property yeah good but the CBS
nuke affiliate there's new comm still
work see there you go like what does
that do yeah it was no idea goes the
game spot really new comm is another you
guys are prolific you're like really
takes over companies and then redirects
them all the games [ __ ] this is like
this is like the video that Alexa and
Rob put together trying to get Cogsworth
to say things and fallout 4 it's like
what names can we make him say just an
endless
yeah you guys did that with dr. google
let's put it in that video and then we
make them all come to our side muah see
ya before Google people just type in
[ __ ] I don't know video games com yeah
and then they came to gamespot yeah so
there you go that was all right that's
the chef of this yeah thanks for this
has been only it works with the folks at
gamespot com there are so many video
games at this week at all talk about a
bunch of today but at one game the
people aren't really talking about
though that too much but as a worth
having a chat about is Verma tight and
Scott Butterworth you reviewed the game
Mary you've played a bunch of it Ascot
first of all what is vermin sighs I
watched upland yeah it's it really
slipped it under the red actually came
out a couple weeks ago during like you
know call of duty just came out and halo
just came out and this asset agreed was
earlier October and now we have fallout
today Tomb Raider it's just it was such
a a packed few weeks of game releases
that I'm not sure anyone really noticed
that this little game came out but it's
it's a game called Warhammer the end
times vermin tide it's a very long title
but it is a Warhammer property said in
the end times lower which is a specific
part of the Warhammer lorg there's a lot
of like there's a lot of stuff in the
universe so is this summer like high
fantasy yeah it's like a very grim dark
high fantasy it's feel like everything's
just dark and gritty and angry and that
and we just look at the trailer right
bits yeah the tone so yeah so basically
what this game is it's it's leopard edge
straight up its valves left for dead but
with rats instead of zombies the skaven
is they're known in the universe but
they're basically as you saw like
humanoid rats would like you know crude
weaponry like that works in lord of the
rings yeah basically yeah and actually i
mean it's it's down the left 4 dead it's
all you know all the details are
straight huddle left four dead including
like the special enemy type 10 special
infected you have like a smoker
equivalent like hunter equivalent like
they're a Boomer in there somewhere
there is yeah yeah there's that the gas
rats they call me like basically fire
gas grenades at you in this huge cloud
of green smoke appears and yeah I mean
so it's it's a pretty shameless
imitation but honestly it's not a bad
thing I mean it actually really works in
a way it's almost impressive that they
have made a game that is as fun and
plays arguably as well as leopard
and with you know I would imagine a
smaller team I mean they don't get a ton
of points for originality because yep
taking about seven years ago but yeah
you can even saw in the last clip like
your allies that you see the glowing
silhouette yeah it's like yeah it's
straight up left for dead Mary you
played a bunch of that for dead one and
two and it has been a while since I left
word that game came out so like what
I've trying to mention not to kinda like
what what's your impression of it did
you enjoy playing it yeah you know you
really sum it up well it's absolutely
there's the hunter you're shameless
change yeah copy but which is it's fine
like it's okay I wanted to play left yet
worst part about left for dead is that
I've played those levels so many times
yeah I can't play them anymore I can't
play them anymore you even did the gnome
run yeah you do all the way you go all
the way and you play in as many
different ways as you can and you play
the vs. modes and everything and you
eventually you're like burn out on it
just suck the dry it's like it's there's
nothing left to kinda yeah it's a new
skin it's so much fun ya know its
meaning melee combat is a huge focus
it's not just you know it obviously left
for dead was guns guns guns guns this
you actually have both ranged and melee
options the melee is somewhat simplistic
I mean there's just it's the trigger
buttons just one button to attacks and
you just aim point your camera than
enemy and pull the trigger till the
thing dies but it's still very
satisfying like it's really gruesome and
the cooperative gameplay you know it's
very fast and frantic in the same way
that left 4 dead was like really hard
focusing on on coops you like you really
really need to work yeah they're just
like in left 4 dead which I loved about
that game right you could not play it
and be a hero you need to work together
yeah you will straight up die ok and get
your whole team killed absolutely and
this incentivizes you to play together
because their secrets throughout the
world and the kind yeah see you in
certain way and there's a loot system
and actually one of the ways to the loot
system works is you can find objects in
the environment that take up an
inventory slots so like you can find a
tome that takes up your medical slot so
you can no longer heal yourself but if
you finish the level while still
carrying that you potentially unlock
better loot and if any any single team
member is carrying a tome everybody
benefits from everybody potentially gets
better loot so that further incentivizes
teamwork it's really actually very
clever the only problem is that the
loose systems like pretty superficial
you kind of run out of new stuff pretty
quickly
okay uh so it's a great idea that I
think could have been executed a little
bit better but still like it's it's very
cool that they even thought to include
ways to force people to work together
and the characters in left 4 dead 12
obviously like very we remember those
characters but they were kind of
standard the generic like there wasn't
much benefit to being one or the other
yeah this are the classes do some people
do magic like how does that's a breaker
they're all different that's really
wonderful too because you can play the
same level as a different character and
have a completely different experience
of course you're seeing the bright
record wizard which is up like basically
a PI romance earlier they have this oh
yeah more distance more range there's
like a bow and arrow person there's a
dwarf that kind of has like big battle
axe I was an area we sort of thing
happen there as well an imperial soldier
with a blunderbuss like a basically a
medieval shotgun so you stuck with the
with the weapons you have to start down
or you know a lot more that's sort of
what the whole loot system is built
around you unlock both new ranged and
melee weapons and actually generally
they're not you know clearly better than
the previous weapon but they might open
up a new play style like to the bright
red we're just looking at the standard
weapon that you start with just kind of
shoots generic fireballs yeah but a
later weapon that you unlock which isn't
as soon and we're powerful but kind of
works differently allows you to sort of
summon fire from across the map so it's
more of an area of effect it's okay as
opposed to like launching projectiles
you can burn a whole bunch or a whole
group a pack that's closely packed
together get them all in like one shot
so it just opens up new options as you
unlocked you were rewarding this is a
sweet level basically like it's actually
I think the first it's one of the very
early one of the early levels and you
blow this horn which oh yes is literary
first level horde of these rats towards
you and then as that happens eventually
a hole in the floor will open up its
extra level but it's like that great end
part of any level where you just know
yeah just Ram saw coming and you gotta
defend for at least like a couple
minutes it's it's just like there's a
whoa smoker oh yeah you're right there
there are pack pack masters in this
which is actually based on something in
warhammer whoa
yes it's it is really rewarding to like
get these final moments you're you're
kind of like bashing into all these
dudes at the very end and trying to
survive so if this is the ending of one
level what are we talking about in terms
of like level the design are not not
designed but like how many levels are
there headed a connect together is there
a narrative that's tying it together
there are 13 levels total they all sort
of stand alone there they're totally
discreet so you can play them in any
order you have to unlock them to begin
with so kind there's this kind of an
order but in terms of story there's no
you know clear progression between them
there you're sort of given justification
for why you're doing this permission as
you start out but they're not
necessarily interconnected that's all
just like oh man the rats are coming
we're bone but let's like stop this
however we can so one mission you're
like trying to recover ammunition
another one you're trying to you know
stymie there you basically infiltrate
escape and base and like destroy their
their home base did you feel compelled
to do the next level or is it kind of
like dropping back to matchmaking and
just doing another random level um it's
the motivation they're certainly know
like narrative motivation to continue
but just the gameplay and the momentum
of fear that feeling of you know you get
the end of a level and it really amped
up because you just you know went
through this whole crescendo at the end
of a level it definitely makes you want
to get to any playing and you can vote
as a team on whether you want to return
to sort of the home base and you check
on your loot or upgrade your systems or
anything or if you just want to jump
directly into the next map like I said
they're sort of designed to be discreet
stand alone and replayable so you can
kind of approach the game everyone you
can just play a ton of missions all in a
row you can do them one at a time and go
back and upgrade your stuff every time
you know it kind of depends on how you
want to approach again warhammer end
times vermin tied seven in a ten on
gamespot com so again before we leave
yeah what are the aspects where does it
kind of fall short I know it's a
multiplayer only kind of focus game it's
30 bucks we're very certain would have
been nice if there had been a versus
mode like in in left 4 dead which was
sort of asymmetrical that you plays the
zombies mom I didn't punish the game too
much for that because it is a lower
price point and I mean that's kind of
ending debate I mean I don't think that
it's a reviewers job to determine the
value of a dollar so I generally don't
really consider price when I'm scoring a
game or you know but I do think that our
certain expectations that come with
point so I didn't you know I would you
know like on this game doesn't have
versus it's a seven out of ten but
something to be mindful of I think a
bigger problem is that the ally AI is
pretty awful Oh see there is nai yes
can't play we were halfway there are
four characters at all times and it's
under you and humans or you and the
computer and they're not trying is dumb
it's garbage and it on garbage like it's
not like in left 4 dead you could play
with AI yeah they were fine they were
fine hard difficulties they were work it
was hard this is like goodbye you can't
get by no already won she don't just
don't dislike run off and do stuff while
you're dying it's like know why come
back in you know I've heard it's gotten
better since launch but i was just
playing the game last week and it was
still clearly a problem I mean that and
like the loot system not being is fully
realized as it probably should have been
was also like not great I think those
those are the big ones those are the big
issues also that it was nice of the
characters were individuals and and
we're a little more unique but none of
them really do anything that's all that
mechanically exciting like yeah you can
aim down sight but it's like okay that's
the thing we can do in a lot of games so
it would have been I see a little more
originality rather than just you know
sort of uninventive new ideas for semi
characters cool interesting gano
Warhammer end times averman tight if you
can get all of those words editing
method was a lot of words a lot of words
seven out of 10 on gay.com available now
on steam for 30 bones and let us know
what you think of verbal time now review
in the comment box below Mike McCarty is
nowhere to be seen just drill where we
can't get them on as real of Duty real
unreliable that guy yeah he asking us
why aren't you talking about the games
we want you to talk about there's a
reason for that yeah my Marty is not
here so we can't talk about call of duty
and we can talk about tomb raider will
review both of those yes very clearly
it's not here hog haha we can talk about
the other one the other one that's the
fort just in case i think about today
okay just in case is not a [ __ ] for
content amana there on the internet a
deal we're gonna talk about Peters
review we're gonna get Peter and Jeff
Chris went on to talk about sort of
glitches in games and how much they can
towards review downtown
but since Mike isn't here we should
probably talk about call of duty Mike
let's just talk about yeah the sukkah
guys talk about money I guess him I like
it really nice sweater on yesterday you
know very beautiful was he so beautiful
this guy apparently he looks like Ben
Affleck is what I've been told or not I
met Ben Affleck uh Matt Damon one of
those two looks like both victims I
gather love chocolate you think a good
will hunting love child the good the one
that came out right not the one that
came out with like six arms right I was
he ate him in the womb yeah that's why
he's so strong anyway here's a woman it
revealed a call of duty modern warfare
ii trays check it out no wait oiled
machine black ops 3 is the replacement
part that keeps the wheels moving for
yet another year the newest iteration of
Call of Duty multiplayer begins on a
promising note as black ops three
specialists cover the screen you still
have the traditional loadout system with
weapons items and equipment but
specialists also provide a new power
weapon or power ability but there's too
much time between specialists unlocks to
keep things moving along and when I'm
not learning the intricacies of a new
character black ops 3 defaults to a more
generic call of duty experience then
there's black ops 3 new zombies map
shadows of evil it's fantastic the
difficulty is high but zombies now more
than ever is a learning experience and
seeing the tangible result of your
practice with co-op partners is
rewarding when it comes to the campaign
black ops 3 is a chore it's a boring
crawl that wastes no time throwing you
into its routine and it's on dead modes
and the first 10 hours of multiplayer
black ops 3 excels but in its campaign
it merely crawls forward black ops 3
doesn't offer anything remarkable to
this series it does just enough to
maintain the call of duty status quo the
franchise however slowly continues its
steady march black ops 3 black ops 3
black ops 3 black ops 3 black ops 3
black ops 3 back upstream black like a
black ops 2 black lobstery black glove
streak alright yeah I won't save mine
warfare 3 hooray until modern warfare 4
comes out call of duty coming again next
year 7 into 10 on gamespot com we're not
here to talk about for that we're sorry
we are and I a talk called you you were
the third to quit getting with Matt the
students probably still right hey what's
up yeah there you go hey what's up folks
what's going on
video games they're back post
apocalyptic video games are back no
longer you have to keep playing Tokyo
jungle cuz fallout 4 its back on
consoles and PC peter brian and alexa
ray korea how you doing hi good isn't it
nice people talk about fall right now I
know yeah but I still can't talk about
like the plot stuff that I want to talk
about cuz no one in the offices finish
that [ __ ] that z2 me up but yeah it's
good to actually like have something to
say about the game in a public way and
people have a lot of opinions about my
opinion do they some people do will kept
away from spoilers for most of this well
for all of this hopefully 910 on gave
all calm hands up if you love and
fallout 4 yeah a bunch of people in the
audience as well this games great I'm
loving it and what is it the sort of
grabbed you Peter what's your experience
at the fault i had franchise and what
wasn't before you read it up fallout 3
was my first game in the series i kind
of dabbled in like the original but yeah
i put in probably I'd say about 30 hours
of fallout 3 which is almost nothing
compared to people who are like hardcore
fans of the series and forgave me a lot
of what I loved about 3 and that is
obviously a lot of opportunity to
explore discover things be surprised by
characters and to start to shape a story
that has a lasting impact Alexa did you
live in Boston for a couple years I
lived in Boston for six years six years
tell me about what you think of the
world of Fallout 4 it was sort of I I
don't know if anyone who actually lives
in Boston can chiming in the comments
here but like walking through Boston and
walking through like like the Fenway is
now like a shantytown like it's it sort
of hurt a little bit it's like all this
no no it's like all crapped up like it
was it was definitely very it was very
poignant for me to sort of walk around
and explore I did a lot of exploring um
but it was really cool to see their
vision of like the post-apocalyptic
wasteland in this like very very like
smart city in the whole like it's the
Institute thing it was also really cool
how they sort of took MIT which was
which is working on secret crap all the
time making it this like big thing it's
interesting because it's a plot point in
three as well that a little bit new
vegas then i guess the the replicated
man a wonderful quest for 53 you can see
some of that sort of
appearing here interesting you say that
because that when i played assassin's
creed syndicate are it made me feel
nostalgic about london oh that's not one
of those things and what did you think
about the world building and fallout 4
appear I thought it was really good
overall it started off very abrupt hmm
you know like we saw a deathclaw earlier
you know 15 minutes into the game you're
fighting that thing yeah and it's like
okay I guess we're really like doing
this you know so yeah there wasn't this
really abrupt start and this transition
from your life as a as I put it in my
review I guess a well-to-do guy from
like a 1950's area lady arwen lady
correct I into this wasteland where like
you know anything goes and whatever you
got to do to survive is the weight its
way to be but you know as it goes on you
begin to meet characters from the
various factions that are keeping Boston
to float as it were as a society
although not very well and navigating
that to me gave me a great sense of the
overall community within the game and by
the end of it I was totally invested in
the lives of everybody I'm totally with
you on the the initial couple of hours
of this game are also they're kind of
jarring in a weird way that so much
stuff is dumped on yourself stuff do you
sort of earn in the older games like
very early on and I was kind of weirded
out by in those past games at least in
three new vegas at the earlier ones of
the to isometric ones as well is that
you sort of you start in an isolated
place and eventually you find the big
sort of red populous area whereas in
this you actually spend most of the
start of the game in the city ya like it
you know you can play whichever way you
want but it wasn't until my later hours
where i started to go ahead and finding
the wilderness yeah where I was like oh
no this map is actually really big and
there's like stuff hidden all over the
place ally those old games as well yeah
yeah i don't know i think that big
dumping in the beginning kind of adds to
the sense of what fallout 4 is like
you're in frozen here's a wasteland find
your baby go and i think kicking you out
of the gate with very little here's how
you do it i think sort of adds to
experience it's very much like it it
adds to that idea that this is an
extension of what fallout 3 and new
vegas where it's i think a much more
accessible game for people who are
familiar with those titles and perhaps
there are some hurdles
that newcomers have to overcome but you
know but then there's also the idea that
it ramps up the action so fast that it
kind of prepares you for the worst in
those opening moments so I feel two ways
about that intro and this is some
footage some gameplay I caught over the
weekend of just the general shooting and
one of the great things about this game
is that you can play this game not
without that's completely but it's a
fairly competent shooter in its own
right right it's simple and functional
you know and you know if for me it was
more of a like a reactionary thing if
there was someone barreling towards me I
would just put a couple of rounds into
them rather than jumping into vats to
like you know plan out every single shot
so for me it was more of a utility than
like a means to enjoy the game but but
yeah it's better than it wasn't three
let's talk about some of the new I guess
features Aminata to the game and some of
which seemed almost like loose ends the
base building settlement stuff I've been
enjoying using it because it's it's kind
of a nice side activity to do like all
that junk you feel like is going towards
something yeah but doesn't really seem
to kind of do anything even when you set
up trade rats right yeah I mean what the
trade routes are good if you really
value repurposing the junk you find to
create stuff because then you can store
things and one part of austin and access
them in another it's convenient you can
also fast travel if you want to get to
the other stuff so it's not like it's
you know inventing some new ability at
large but yeah like the settlement stuff
didn't really draw me in and I think
it's because you know I've I've gone
into fallout 2 to do the exploration and
discovery in the combat and to pull me
away from that I need something that's
really rewarding or challenging this to
me was neither of those things you could
you know people there's like some small
side quests to people like hey we really
need some beds and maybe a roof it
doesn't matter how you slap that
together yeah they're just like sweet
i'm gonna go take a nap thnx here's 20
experience points if you put six beds
out in the middle of like a yard fine
yeah and if you look at a game like
fortnight right uh that is a game I
don't think it's out yet right i think
maybe it's just in beta that's it you
can use it on them yeah i mean that is a
game
around this idea and an idea that was
sort of taken from games like minecraft
in a way but but in for tonight you know
you can take things in your environment
repurpose them and then you put all that
to the test and then it really becomes
focused and you know around what you've
built and I guess maybe in light of that
this didn't feel that great and in light
of the other other content it wasn't
compelling to me it's completely
optional all right you don't actually
add for anything there's some stuff you
have to do later using the same
interface but it's not in the vein of
building a settlement it's a no vein of
constructing something to help someone
accomplish a thing cool nice and vague i
like it was the main quest have you been
enjoying that Alexa so I'm almost done I
know Peters almost done I've sort of I
sort of wandered off and started doing a
bunch aside stuff um I sort of really
like the idea of you like running along
in this waistline looking for like your
kid I know a lot of people are like Oh
captured infant subplot but it's so
interesting like like you you're you
don't know where you are in the timeline
when you unfreeze so in your head like
I'm thinking like oh like it's still a
baby yeah wait a minute no is it like an
adult yeah who knows right yeah what if
it's actually two hundred like he was
stolen at the outset and he's like dead
and all his grandchildren are like
you've no idea he kind of don't know
right so you're looking for this person
that you don't know what they look like
you don't know what they're called and
it's just like I don't know and I did it
as a woman so I liked this idea of like
having this like deranged mother running
around the waistline becoming this
terror looking for her kid yeah i
actually prefer the female voice acting
quite a lot what the hell is going on
here this is this a thought this was
before the nuclear apocalypse wow that's
oh there you go it's my goodies ooh
that's some nice comes a mustache I see
a hairline you gotta get a mustache in
there oh oh no I'll kill him on fire
Kelly with we're all beautiful we're all
hydroformed Barry looks like totally
yeah but yeah there we go nailed it yeah
I prefer the the female voice actor and
it also kind of yeah it felt a little
bit more real like mother running after
child rather than because if I don't
know the father the dude I don't know
especially he looks like this is a
strike I don't know it doesn't come
across as earnest them for me anyway mmm
can't talk about my quest little bit yes
go for me I think that in
so many people I talked to love the side
stories and I found a lot of them to be
very interesting but as the main quest
went on and especially in the final act
of it man do things just come together
in a way that you you really didn't see
coming over and and it drags other
people into the line of fire that you
have you know befriended or helped in
certain ways and you're forced to make
choices that it's like you're set you're
always like making a sacrifice I'm
trying to imagine that there is a way to
play this where you don't have to
sacrifice anything or anyone but I can't
see it but I can see a lot of ways where
the what you sacrifice changes and that
to me was like I'm sitting there like
man this decision I'm about to make and
then afterwards like man I really want
to know what else would have happened
like more than the side quest stuff the
main quest wants makes me want to play
the game more and again yeah from the
start I'm not as far as either of you
and on the main quite stuff I mostly
done side stuff and but i have to agree
i think this is probably its think it's
the best man course insta series went 3
d I know four threes main quest was kind
of not really that grated you went to
the same place as a lot it was kind of
short you can complete a pretty short
new Vegas was interesting cuz I've had
all the different you know organizations
you could join inside wouldn't why not
but it was still kind of a little bit
benign at the end so is there a lot of
like siding with different specific
organizations and all that sort of stuff
yeah and there's no for some of them
it's like okay this is obviously a good
person this is a bad person or faction
but those lines become blurred the
further you get into the story and
you're choosing sides or you don't want
to like it's it's so tough it's so tough
like right up until the vet to till the
final minute you're just racking your
brain what do i do like what's more
important to me what do I value the most
and you know the game I don't think this
is spoiling things too much because we
already know the institute is involved
and people know the institute is
involved in creating cyborgs essentially
and it sort of raises these questions
like similar to you know themes that
come up in Blade Runner yes which is
probably more popular than Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep the source for a
lot of this these discussions but you
know you deal with sort of deciding like
you know what is human
like at what point you know when
someone's looking at you and pleading
for something and you've traveled with
them but they're a robot you know how do
you have you ever decide like know all
of that doesn't matter yeah but you come
to a point where you have to make a few
of those decisions and that's that I was
surprised I did not see that plot line
coming at all cool in this game all
right looking forward to hearing more
about that and let's talk a little bit
we're gonna get Jeff on Grossman on from
John bottom in a sec to talk about sort
of glitches and how they enter into the
review process and I've had a bunch of
glitchy [ __ ] happen I played maybe like
30 hours on different consoles and stuff
and but nothing that like it's that
weird thing we're like I kind of I'm
expecting this almost from a bethesda
game either whiteley or wrongly and how
did the glitches and the sort of
problems with frame raider or bugs and
why not factor into your review played
the vast majority this game on
PlayStation 4 I noticed the frame rate
drop a few times it was not a frequent
thing at least to the point where it was
really noticeable to me the glitches
themselves that they they exist and
they're funny they make me laugh it
breaks immersion in that sense and it's
not commendable I'm not going to say
good job Bethesda for shipping a buggy
game that's what we love it
characterizes some of their games that
are like fallout but the important
things that I was discussing before and
even the moment-to-moment action and
storytelling exploration stuff that
trumped any glitch that I saw like yeah
I'd laugh I'd laugh them off doesn't
mean they don't exist but they don't
actually took matter to me so uh you
know the the score the game got was not
it wasn't like it was a ten and because
there were glitches it was a nine it
earned the nine the glitches just
happened to exist within that that
paradigm cool I peter brian alexa ray
corriea thank you so much going on
talking about fallout 4 there is no
shortage of 4i for content on gamespot
talk on right now and we've been playing
this for obviously over a week so far I
have a bunch of content up on the side
content got a company by said that word
videos and [ __ ] for you to check out on
gangs barn youtube so i go do that if
you want more fallout 4 goodness all
right we'll be back to the second Jeff
crispim job on comms gonna come on talk
a little bit about fallout 4 but first
of all
it was n seven day you know that is
something to do and that's a fact sure
is november seventh so they put at a
trailer for Mass Effect Andromeda
starring what was that guy who was in
that TV show Andromeda was that guy's
name Hercules yes I was like yes what
thank you Kevin solo
we are travelers
constantly moving forward and looking
back
alone and is one
we have no choice but to try
for our insatiable curiosity
for our fear what should happen if we
don't
you are that Explorer now
we will say goodbye and you will look
back one last time
and know that wherever you go we will be
with you this is commander shepard
signing off Paul a 4k met this week it's
a good video game do we agree gentlemen
I think it's a great video do you
depends which platform you're playing on
oh really yeah oh right yeah what are
you even playing on I so are you just
went up reviews i guess i should say
okay and i played through it on ps4
because that's what they sent first
wounds the console versions of the game
and then pc followed up i wish they had
done it the other way around because the
pc version that game is significantly
better so you did two reviews well so
the text is identical because you know
we always figure that you know people
that are playing one version would want
to know about the other versions so
rather than just tailor the text
differently but yes so the pc got four
stars and the console version got three
so speak about i guess about the
technical issues you came on the console
version or the ps4 bro i mean the the
framerate is a train wreck in that game
you know depending on where you are it
just you know indoor areas seem to
perform worse than the outdoor areas you
know it started near the beginning of
the game noting like every time you
reload the gun is just like why is so
chunky and then just progressively as
you keep playing like wait this isn't
look right this doesn't look right then
you know a lot of the framerate stuff
specifically culminated in a late game
moment for me you're kind of you're in a
large area I'm going to try to talk
vaguely yeah you're in kind of a large
area but it's catwalks so it's kind of a
tight moving movement space maybe about
a dozen enemies it was kind of hard to
count them at some point because there
were more enemies on the screen than
frames per second you know it was like
baby five frames per second or something
you know and it's like if I'm trying to
like at some point you can't aim the gun
when it's that bad that's doesn't freeze
time so right that's not a like a great
option either to shoot your way through
that thing so it just became like well I
need to heal every 15 seconds to keep my
health up and try to use all of my
stealth boys to get out of here back to
where the framerate lives it's crazy
because when we
in office obviously as well in the past
week or so I played maybe like 15 hours
on Xbox one favor it wasn't you know it
was like I paid our PC subsequently and
it was like a difference yeah and but it
never really got like super bad honest I
was in sometimes like the God raised in
the forest during the day but it never
crunched bad like that did you
experience that much when you're playing
did the only moment that I experienced
that is as bad as you're describing was
within a building where they were trying
to do some sort of like particles smoke
effect thing and it was the first time I
had seen it and seen framerate that bad
but I never had any sort of like moment
where the glitches like or frame rate
rather impacted the my abilities in
combat right um I mean I've heard a lot
of people say similar things I'm
surprised to hear is that bad for you
yeah and it's you know and the xbox one
version you know has that kind of you
know those digital foundries piece was
kind of like talking about just
straight-up stopping and then the
recommendation there seems to be play
the game off an external hard drive
which I this point actually play because
USB 3 is faster than whatever they had
an eternal in the SATA so I've actually
I moved to an external hard drive on
Xbox one a while ago so i'm laying that
version i didn't see anything quite as
bad as what people had talked about but
it certainly was you know right around
ps4 levels of performance for me so yeah
those versions of the game just have an
extra layer i mean these games are
always messed up right i mean bethesda
ships buggy weird games but in this case
like the console versions were just an
extra level of messed up muesli i can't
either this isn't well it's a bizarre
can't recommend this anymore it's a
bizarre echo of the playstation to
preheat version yeah we're gonna yeah
things like they sneak a Cell processor
into the pip-boy that comes with it or
something like yeah messed up so i guess
like let's talk about glitches in terms
of when new games come here because
obviously like there have been some
absolute horror shows over the past
couple years we've had our anniversary
this time last year like batman arkham
knight is just command and pc apparently
it's still jacked up a little bit yeah 3
our people nowadays kind of more
sensitive to glitches because of those
types of stories or is this the same as
it's ever been I think games are ship
in lesser states you know like like
games you know as games get more and
more complicated so they don't have an
infinite amount of dollars in time to
throw at QA and then you know and fix
all these things prior to ship and you
know it's hard to say I every games
gonna have a different story attached to
it whether it's like well they must
manage the time and just didn't have
time to you know really get a final
polish pass on it or or whatever it's
hard to know and it's hard to care
because at the end of the day like
people buy a game they expect it to work
and these days that's just seemed less
and less certain you know I just came
off of yeah I mean obviously like the pc
version of batman is super crazy yeah
you know they took it off sale for a
while and brought it back out and i are
still people having problems with it
that you know it at least they're
offering refunds through the end of the
year with that one you know instead of
like a yeah what hey maybe if you had 12
gigs of ram my can wait doesn't this run
on consoles that dont have it anyway but
it's crazy that there are games like
that which have so many people having
problems with them like anecdotally one
of my best mates back home in Ireland
but what that game didn't read any news
about worked perfectly fine completed it
before it was taken down right is it
just gotten so difficult to like QA this
stuff because i don't know like well he
was saying so different their games are
becoming so much more complicated and
the tech behind them is so much more
complicated that these intricacies
create moments so many moments where
things can just go wrong and go haywire
and that's the thing that you know it is
specifically talking about fallout like
I mean sometimes it works right all
right yeah you know fallout allows you
to do so many different things and pick
up so many different like there's so
many different places where fallout can
break yeah more so than most other games
so it maybe it's not surprising sorry
that it's so busted but that doesn't
make it forgivable but yeah I like its
place sometimes it's awesome but in the
fallout case like those games been
broken the exact same way since oblivion
if not before and at some point it's
like well you know yeah it's roll the
dice like I've been on the other end of
the conversation we're having right now
where I finished new vegas and said this
game's fine yeah and then people are
like you're
crazy um so that's just how it goes
sometimes so what is that just like a
deeply personal thing or is it an
expectation thing because like going
into playing fallout I'm like okay last
night i was playing just three super
mutants all there and i blow to them up
and then the third one is there still
stirring the pot as if nothing happened
what's her and I'm like his father
whereas if that was like a you know well
half life 3 I might go hey that's
[ __ ] yeah I think that you know
people maybe gotten conditioned to
expect these games to be messed up and
and maybe that's certainly part of it
but I don't know for me I think the
expectations were not met because I
looked at it like well you know they've
been making these games for a very long
time they've had these issues all along
but now they're moving on to a new
generation of technology their baseline
their low spec for consoles will be up a
rung yeah and on x86 hardware you know
so you looking like well maybe there are
now fewer variables and they could
actually tighten some of this stuff up
but then I sent my dog companion away
and never saw it again you know but then
I spent an hour trying to click on a
quest objective and having it not
activate and having to fast travel away
and back and read launch the game
multiple times before it would actually
do anything and you know that's all
stuff that you know those are all
stories that could just as easily apply
to new vegas fallout 3 Skyrim oblivion
but you know for me it's one of those
things where it's like we want to expect
more out of our games you know
technology improves and you'd think that
they would have gotten better at this
stuff but apparently they spent their
time somewhere else and that's maybe the
larger problem is i look at fallout 4
and i don't know where they spent that
time right because it's not like it's a
massive difference yeah you know the
workshop stuff the the base building
stuffs in there for whatever reason and
it seems like a natural evolution of
their in-house development that they
figured hey we can just add this to the
game why not Yeah right we'd like
something new to show at e3 let's just
show this just do this like you know
people that modded the game liked
building bases at some point so maybe
they wanted to just do that but it's one
of the things where it's like you look
at it and go like this is roughly the
same as previous games that the studio
has made it doesn't necessarily seem
larger in
go pour smaller it's just kind of that
thing so for it to ship out again and be
more or less just as glitchy and messed
up as their previous games i think is
super crazy and stepping away from
fallout 4 specifically it this is sort
of getting into the realm of conspiracy
theory but you know with the advantages
of people having high bandwidth internet
connections and the pervasiveness of day
one patches now like our developers and
publishers shipping games with packed
with bugs and short fallings knowing
that they can scrap them or patch them
up later on oh I totally think so a lot
of game development is driven by
milestones where a publisher says we
need you to hit X feature on X date
otherwise you will lose budget and
they'll be other ramifications so when
you have strict milestones like that and
then it comes closer and closer to
shipping you really need to start you
know hitting those what I understand to
to make the whole thing worthwhile and
yes there is the nature of updates and
DLCs now that we've all kind of grown
accustomed to and have thus made it
capable for publishers and developers to
make excuses and stuff it's not great
but I think that that is why I'm sure
you know it's it's a handful of things
you know the disks have to be pressed X
number of days before they're on the
streets so they have to be you know
they're not done on Street donde one
they're done a month before that and
then it's like okay now we need this
extra time to work on whatever this day
one patch is gonna be or you know start
working on DLC or whatever it ends up
being you know back before you could
just patch a console game you'd run into
things that you know i remember it was
one of the tomb raider games on ps2 i
believe where they shipped it broken and
it was just something that was like well
this is a bad glitch and the console
manufacturer waived it and said you can
ship you know it was they called it a
running rev they're like okay look you
can put out this many copies of this
game and then you fix this thing and
reshipping so they were basically
willing to allow a certain number of
copies with you know and it wasn't like
something that every single user was
going to find right ankle there's
something along the lines that they
forgot to put in a weapon but they put
the ammunition in maybe it was like the
[ __ ] one of the shotguns wasn't I never
ended up hearing the back end of it of
like what the problem actually was it
was more just like someone in PR going
like yeah by the way this copy we're
shipping is going to be
rare why because we're working on
exclusive j 1 edition right the day one
edition more broken so you know this
sort of stuff used to happen then too
you know Nintendo Wii point made people
should send cartridges back to them
replaced and stuff like that there there
are definitely multiple versions of
games like Star Fox and super mario
all-stars and stuff like that that just
kind of quietly were revved in the
background so you know that's been going
on a long time it's just now we have the
power to fix these things and I think a
lot of people complain about day one
patches but it's the way of things the
alternative of like setting all this
stuff in stone isn't going to instantly
fix all these problems and make them
glitch free as much as we'd like to
believe that like that would force them
to get it right the first time it
wouldn't it wouldn't you know it made my
claim some things but like these things
are there are too many moving parts and
there are too many marketing oriented
you know they have to either ship day
you know they're not that many big games
coming out anymore but they announced
their dates so far in advance that like
there's so much money being spent on
marketing campaigns and television and
sponsorships and all this other stuff
all these you know twitch streamers that
have to get their game in so they can
start streaming a lot and these are the
things that give people the budgets to
make the games that we're talking about
to yeah you know like that's the sort of
stuff that if we want the games that we
love like fallout better there's these
big expansive games to continue we kind
of have to buy into that system
otherwise where's the money going to
come from yeah it's it's a tricky
problem there are a ton of moving parts
on all ends that thing that are just
kind of systemic to the way that big
games get developed a produced market
and shipped and it sounds like it's if
what you guys are saying is correct it
sounds like this is something that we're
not going to see less of we could
possibly see more of it well you know
nothing's been quite as broken as a
Assassin's Creed unity yeah yeah has it
you know look I Batman you could say
well okay yeah babble it but that's only
one version of it so that better or
worse I don't even know me I'd like to
think that we've kind of crossed a
threshold where the leaps in technology
and scope of games is starting to like
level out a little bit and so maybe
these sort of huge ambitious projects
will seem relatively normal in light of
regular development and so hope you
don't people learn their lessons fallout
4 is a good example of how that didn't
happen yeah yeah but no one's going to
learn
the lesson learned from fallout 4 is
going to be hey look at us we just sold
another 20 million copies of a game we
were broken just as broken is the last
one which also sold 20 million copies
and you know likes no one's going to
learn anything but could they do it
again could they [ __ ] that's the yeah I
guess that's the questions like could
the next bethesda game studios game be
this messed up yeah i'd like to think no
yeah i would i would definitely like to
think no but I guess I'll find out get
another seven year five years oh yeah
nah my new vegas is that like wat 18
months after three so for sierra city to
skyrim too right yes skyla Elder Scrolls
online is gonna kill your guy remember
for a new like single-player Elder
Scrolls game time soon they're probably
way too behind that so Jeff cross your
fingers a dude works properly do plays
well from what I played it plays
wonderfully I've played the multiplayer
stuff it's a different engine though to
osu that's just that's the EdTech engine
is broken in an entirely different way
Oh every game John Goodman [ __ ] REI link
at that point oh really yeah you just
get John Goodman automatically in can't
wait Jeff Gerstmann peter brian like you
so much for coming on telling us how
broken video games are let us know how
broken you think video games are in the
comment box below gentlemen that's
almost a show you have to give away some
schwag okay okay i didn't even get to
talk about how busted need for speed was
oh don't talk about how bus names meters
yeah you know I tried to buy a car it
failed it just came back and said
purchase fail does your credit was [ __ ]
I guess so using using in-game currency
there's no there's no like buy cars with
real money in that game yet it failed
the purchase but yet the car showed up
in my garage it wouldn't let me get in
it and it took the money so I couldn't
travel so I couldn't try to buy another
one it's like a look at it yeah right so
I had to dig into the menus and
eventually like nine layers deep there's
something that just says play alone and
we do that it disconnects you from all
the servers and then the car was usable
play alone play alone that's about the
most depressing menu option I've ever
heard story in my life Danny all right
let's give away I got this body bag here
who's in it find out by winning it this
is a one of two prizes were giving away
on the show today and this one is a hail
a five army bag it's got a halo
controller headset a sweater let's just
open it that's just open I'm a knight
open the right smells like day one of
school oh it's got a 950 cap it's got a
bunch of them check what is it 92
sticker on that's how you know you're
sure you keep the sticker oh the sticker
off well it's why we sell our hats and
the Giant Bomb store with a sticker on
you it should say cheers yeah don't
stickers so you have one to take off or
it who to look ok double bad yes I left
the tabs on my couch when I bought it we
had an extreme example of this behavior
don't you have to is that like illegal
no no this was like the tags describing
its features like it was substrate at
Bell Biv DeVoe type business that's what
on it we've got a new car this year did
you leave all the plastic [ __ ] all over
the there is one tiny plastic down and
down on the passenger side below the
glove box they look at go I should take
that off who cares here's a halo shirt
it's got halo on it Wow look at that
halo right on it it's subtle see that we
got this sweater I'm not gonna be able
to get all this back in the bag this
sweater also has halo written on I think
says extreme space combat like a sweater
dude that's how I play my video games
just like a sweater like a sweater
sweating all day halo 5 Guardians
official guide shoot the dude she's like
what baby run forward hit fire I like
halo 5 but come on here we go halo 5
Guardians master chief controller I'm a
fan of a weird custom controllers that's
Alex product looks alright where's my
lock controller thank you you don't get
to could you oh my god this just
weirdness in here what is this thing I
don't even know what thought you figure
out what that it's a boy I've no idea
mega bloks boyee oh man Goodell never
opened since before do you like sand
rocks by Kazuma Jeannot Jeannot Ichi
it's right there hello five the
soundtrack it's a good sound I remember
yeah joining the music in that game do
you enjoy halo 5 yeah yeah the guy
seemed to enjoy it on your extra live
stream over the weekend yeah it's it's a
good time I think there's some stuff
with a multiplayer that maybe should
have been a little not they're not as
bad as master chief collection hey ya go
if yeah if we're now judging games by
not as broken as some of the most broken
games that have shipped than ever
here's a some ridiculous look at the
connector for that controller this is a
pair of headsets you need just you can
stick this thing into your controller
you got a for this thing's almost almost
add you don't worry everyone is so up on
these Astro headsets yeah they're comfy
I'm not a big fan I never not been this
is this too much yeah I like you but we
fall in different sides can agree on the
classics get this guy look at this
here's a hair oh it is actually a halo 5
branded a squirt gun it's a it's a
blaster whatever it's got slide action
get blasted it's got a covenant one so
you can be covenant guy and also has
this sweet things he can shoot at what I
assume is a covenant no it's another
thing let me call those guys robot man
robot man instead of grunt I can't see
look at him is that for kids or
Millennials it's safe I've been
technically I'm a millennial I know me
too and there's the body bag you can you
can ice your friend who beat you in halo
multiplayer and may have to cut them in
half written about you I don't wanna
have to is like implies that it's not
yet already on your list yeah things to
do if you want to win this ridiculous
and this is now the awesome part of the
show where he tries to fit all this
crest I back in again I know I got 10
minutes to get to the air what you two
did for unpacked why should I break this
prize i think they built the bag around
the stuff oh [ __ ] really it's like when
you get an extension and you leave the
piano on the building site so they can
just say to fit it in there yes i'm
probably right every day i run into that
one I heard crack it's no custom my god
it's custom yeah let's go home I / them
what was this I didn't even see I was to
win this all you have to do is follow
gamespot on Twitter and then hit retweet
on a tweet they're gonna do there it is
there is Mary doing a way better job of
showing you all of the things that are
in this bag and also showing you the
back just retweet that and you have a
chance to win this thing I'm almost got
it done these should be the soft easy
it's right cuz it yeah just kind those
in wherever
as in life cramming in wherever this is
better than fallout 4 I I once one of
GameSpot UK a hit man I don't know which
one I think I might have blood money
like bad like this okay had a bunch of
stuff on us mmm my dad uses the bag for
his like golf equipment straight up has
like hitman written on the side of it
with two [ __ ] guns yeah and he's like
going to a golf and they probably think
he's the most savage golf around and he
keeps like everyone someone gets the
links there like all right man back oh
man is he exactly art like no he was
writing a note for me like when I was
home during the summer time I'm this big
piece paper and you handed it to me and
it was like the hit man no paper i got
he's still got it okay i thought you
were gonna say he signed it is really
leave it into this out of your way back
yeah we've also got something else to
give away we got an xbox one of fallout
4 and to win that bad boy there should
be a link on scary to China ah oh you
also have to just follow that apparently
there's a link where's that link guys
just just follow gamespot and they've
got the link cuz then that way you don't
have to type it in manually off this
stream cuz you can't click on text
that's on video yet that's coming in
HTML six and so make sure you follow
gamespot on Twitter and then you get a
link to that you can also in five four
xbox one or an xbox one will fall out
for hair she did would it be at the same
person one both be shitty I don't know
man you know it's all xbox one stuff it
all goes together yes sir I'd be and and
we could say we as a company the
corporate we could save on shipping oh
that's true i expect us you know so you
did competition in the UK where we gave
away the Dovahkiin oh [ __ ] statue
yeah ah which sucked yeah is it touched
shutting on that is yeah it's like nine
boxes it's a likely so we have to drive
to Wales I was so happy to leave that
when we moved out of our old office
leaving that dumb thing behind like I
remember I didn't even necessarily want
to build it when it showed up your smell
yeah it's like weird PLAs yeah or smell
real bad you guys got one for fallout
yeah yeah I guess I guess we're just not
on the cool Bethesda list anymore well
we got this one I was already this guy's
here already yeah my last one don't eat
it no yeah
we got enough garbage over there the
frame you sent us that's not you see
cases something really like for the same
joystick bwe yep yeah I got to WWE
all-stars joy 6 for ps3 yes I just got a
copy of a Nancy Drew game for the pc and
over there the great let's sent over
yeah we good that we get the hotmail
over there you got hotmail oh yeah well
that's on the corporate mail system
[ __ ] all right thanks Jeff
thanks Pierre for come around Thanks
adds everyone for watching lobby this
week yeah thanks packing it I let us
know what you think of the show in the
comments below we'll be back next week
with more hot fallout 4 goodness and
body bags see you then oh one more thing
well there you go extra lives on this
weekend gamespot is streaming from this
very character a shin from noon on
friday we're doing it for 72 hours we
got 12 hours here 12 hours in the UK 24
hours from my place and then 24 hours of
just McDonald at the end 72 hours at
tiny URL com /g s extra life that's jise
extra life at donate cash and to watch
all the details on scheduling and all
that so yeah we'll be back on Friday for
more hot video game live streaming
goodness but until then have fun bye
you